Jesse Teddy congratulations you boys
have made it to the final round of this
competition now we're sending you back
to your home forges to recreate this
this is a Musketeers Rapier
oh dear next stop I'll be pre-testing
the Musketeers Rapier
your raper's supposed to be light swords
I'm expecting at least a lot of
harassing guts harassing guts are be
able to move at a distance and just cut
deep Cuts with a tip so the movements
that we do are light movements light
Cuts so that later on we can go in for
the Finish originating in the early
1600s the Musketeers Rapier was the
distinctive weapon of the colorful
French Musketeers of the Guard
these Elite troops were the first line
of defense for French royalty featuring
a thin Diamond profile blade that tapers
down to a point it's extreme lightweight
made it excellent for quick slashing
cuts and pinpoint stabs
in addition the weapons double clam
shell guard aided in defense by
protecting the user's hand especially
during one-on-one duels tales of the
swashbuckling Musketeers are world
famous to this day and can be seen in
the film The Three Musketeers
thank you
foreign
carcass because it's something that we
can understand when we see the cuts it's
very close to just basically its skin
some other mediums have a very thick
hide a lot of hair so you can really see
the cuts with the pig carcass when it
cuts like that you can see the immediate
damage that it does very visual
when I'm using the Rapier I'd like to
see all these nice Cuts as I'm moving
them around for every movement pop oh
that simple move like a whip has a very
deep cut so the patterns we see on the
figure is like just writing a canvas
this is what we do this is the motions
and this is how deep the cuts are
[Music]
all right
now it's awesome to see these musketeer
blades cut a pig in half but in reality
they're not supposed to they're not
supposed to be that heavy some of the
tests will go wow that really perform
well but it's not supposed to function
that way if it's a heavy sword you're
just gonna leave it at home good luck
gentlemen we'll see you in four days
good luck holy crap
my name is Teddy Royer and I'm a welder
for an excavation company My Wife puts
up with a lot in the garage with a forge
and not enough room for her car so she's
hoping I win to show it's not wasted
garage space it's useful so I'm using
5160. it's tough It's springy Rapier
since they're so thin they are meant to
flex a little bit so that's what we're
going with I've got the tire plate
shaped it's beveled I'm satisfied
[Music]
it's not biting it's not skating quite
right I realize I have to re-quench I
have to re-harden this I just want to
make sure that when it gets to the
judges it's going to survive whatever
they throw at it
I've seen any warps so
hard the elements I have to get finished
are the knuckle bow two side bars and a
pommel there's a knuckle bow the fan
finish that I'm going to put on it it's
gonna look rugged but clean pretty and
just overall well-constructed piece ten
thousand dollar worthy No Doubt all
right
Jesse Ewing's my name 34 years old and I
kill bugs for a living Pest Control good
stuff
I know that to come on Forge and fire is
a huge undertaking however I know that I
have the skills and passion to go all
the way
so I'm gonna go with far stock size of
adcrv2 super strong should hold up very
well to the testing that's going to be
the hardest part because I don't know
what it has to survive with all the
factors involved in this quench the low
roof of the garage the tall quench tank
a ladder just to breach above it
I'm hoping that I can get it right the
first time
catastrophically the sword drops out of
my hands I hear the tip hit the bottom
of the tank I pull the sword out of the
quench I see this huge bow
I gotta get this thing in my
straightening jig I have no idea what's
going to come out I'm really scared I'm
really nervous hoping for the best and
praying for a miracle
so the swords cooled off in the
straightening jig let's see if I just uh
performed a miracle here it's time to
open it up and see what's inside
holy crap
there's slight warpage on there but
nothing crazy that I can't fix with a
grinder
she's hard I've never made a sword
before so I'm ecstatic right now so with
my blade mostly done and I've already
got the clamshell guard fitted out guard
fits
for this handle I'm going to go with a
nice hardwood and offset that with
different color Micarta and then epoxy
together so I can shape it off of the
sword oh gosh I go to remove the handle
and she's stuck
I really don't know what the heck to do
at this point
seriously contemplating taking this
thing to the bandsaw and I look at The
Sword and the rear part is separated
I think I can save this
try it again second time imagine that
and that's how it should have went the
first time
yeah that came together pretty nice with
the time I got left I'm gonna start
shaping all these quillians and knuckle
bows and all that fruit stuff on the
handles
the blade itself I'm pretty much happy
with the geometry of it but I want to
see if I can remove some weight at the
tip I want Doug to be swinging that
thing all over the place and having a
good time with it
so now that everything's permanently
fixed just gotta clean it up sharpen up
a little bit
I can't wait to see the judges test this
thing all right bladesmiths welcome the
kill test
I'm gonna take your rapierce and deliver
some killing slashes and thrusts on this
big carcass for these musketeer swords
it's time to find out if you're all for
one Champion or one for all the
runner-ups Jesse you're up first you
ready for this let's cut some bacon
dude
you gotta work out
all right Jesse this Edge
is sharp a Rapier cut a big in half
that's very interesting for every slash
The Edge lands exactly where I want it
to be okay overall sir for this test
all right ready Teddy let's do it
thank you
laughs
all right Teddy your Edge when you're
slashing with the razor's Edge that you
have on your blade it slices easily and
deeply on this big carcass your weapon
sir
will kill
awesome nice
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test little thing I like to
call the wheel of pain
now a Rapier needs to be a fast light
flexible weapon we're going to see how
flexible yours are all right Jesse so
I've got your blade strapped into our
wheel of pain right now now I'm going to
be flexing it in both directions I'll be
taking it all the way to that far red
Peg
holding it for about three seconds and
we'll see if it comes back true and then
we're going the other direction all
right go nuts
foreign
are you kidding me okay Jesse
first off remarkable but I mean there's
a lot of weight in this blade a lot of
mass so to have it Flex the way it did
and come back virtually to true this
blade is still straight enough to fight
with which is excellent thank you good
job thank you
Teddy you ready for this let's do it
foreign
crap
there's a pretty significant
Bend from the blade I'm definitely
terrified at this point
so Teddy you can see where it took the
bins here and here and the initial bend
it actually bent this way and then we
bent it back and it went the other way
so it leaves some question about the
heat treat you know how how even it is
through the blade you know it's just
I worry about that bend
so guys
I mean you know it's a finesse weapon
these things are about speed and
accuracy and light and fast
blade Smith's a Musketeers Rapier is a
finesse weapon and Teddy unfortunately a
less than perfect heat treat has led to
your Rapier taking a permanent Bend now
this is going to affect accuracy when it
comes to the use of the weapon in our
sharpness test and for that reason this
is the catastrophic failure and you
cannot continue with this competition
come on forward my friend
I've had a blast I've made a few good
friends I've been able to take time and
build something I otherwise wouldn't
have built so that experience has been
great
Jesse congratulations you are the
fortune fire champion and that is the
title that comes with a check for 10
grand good job brother
[Applause]
hard labor
I proved to myself that I'm capable to
do a whole lot more than I thought I
could
thank you